souviens de ton papa quand ils voulaient
de vendre je vous dit c'est plus au papa
il m'a vendu
ça veut dire est d'avoir un petit garçon
moi je veux bien ouais oui tu viens d co
je vais fait à 8 milles 1
ouais mais ça c'est pas accrocheur je
vais me je voulais me à 12000 ce matin
mais les gens s'accrochent pas quoi mais
il est tout option il est à wil et
millions
j'ai pas d'argent je suis au bout du
rouleau et votre enfant ouais iran qu il
n'y a pas de honte entier métier préféré
qu'il soit dans la rue avec moi les
voitures vendez votre voiture c'est un
vrai nom je peux pas vendre ma voiture
et je m'en sers dans la voiture ou votre
enfant vous le vendez il fait bien dans
sa caisse voulu donner des boîtes à
manger
et vite son assiette lâcher
bon alors 3005
en fait moi même
il le sent une leçon qu'ils
n'ont quand même pas nés qui agirait pas
parce que moi je suis de la spa jeu mais
je vendrai un chien sur les pays en deux
fois si ça vous arrange pas fait de
chèques le deuxième je le mets à la fin
du mois à une question alors encore une
question et c'est gratuit pourquoi vous
demandez est ce que vous savez tout ça
parce que j'aimais et les problèmes
d'argent ouais j'ai joué au casino j'ai
tout perdu sur le 8
il faut que je rembourse pas ce que
j'allais faire un frein et puis ils
rigolent pas là bas
et la mer d'autres la mère elle n'est
pas au courant je veux pas qu'elle le
sache je vais lui dire que je les ai
perdus en phr avis de recherche s'il
retrouve pas bon voilà pas pu
on ira aux autres j'ai trouvé pire
si c'est sérieux déjà
ça s'achète pas même si j'avais les
moyens engagés les papiers j'ai tous
avec vous n'avez plus qu'à signer et
faire le chèque moi c'est une chose vous
savez une autre mais à l'enfance il faut
demander son avis si on met d'accord
t'es d'accord victoire
[Musique]